here's what would happen if bitcoin  suddenly got banned  well the first thing is technically no  one can ban bitcoin in the sense that it  would be completely wiped off the  internet cryptocurrencies like bitcoin  are completely decentralized and aren't  on one specific server or tied to a  specific company but countries could  choose not to use any form of crypto and  if the united states or countries in  europe chose to ban it then prices would  completely plummet similar to how an  elon musk's tweet can change the price  of doge or bitcoin so would a country  choosing to prohibit it  you could still technically use and  trade the currency through some shadier  methods but if enough countries banned  bitcoin it would turn into more of a  niche currency or something more novel  instead of the currency of the future so